for me I see people for what it is I see
things for what is I'm trying to sell
lead or rehab because are you I got a
friend that's got a rehab you go down
Lee why triathlete so send Lee to him
because he could make money there's a
rehab there's a bunch of rehabs in
Florida you go to and they get your
insurance and they bang your insurance
460 and then they give you a cutback in
I totally let me send you down I'm into
my buddies give me a 10 percent I get 3
grand you go down they get acupuncture
to give you a few massages imagine who
lease I out would be in terms of his
marijuana consumption imagine where he
would be if it wasn't for you like there
is that guy when you first started
having him on your show when you guys
first started doing this smoke pot maybe
three times in college a couple months
in he's done superhero doses of edibles
couple months in I mean like little by
little little by little but when you
would sneak him in on him and you would
take away at 250 and pointed a 500 what
I would wrap it this the Joey Diaz
co-star in the Church of what's
happening now is completely asleep at
the wheel
he's on the show and his eyes are almost
totally closed he's barely a slip he's
just dazed who's the guest who is that
it's random Basia a kid that I told on
this podcast he can't take it though hi
what is the name of this video Jamie Lee
and I'll espresso lee-sia
in aerospace look at him go he's God I
would get these okay I would go in the
afternoons and I would get a 180 and I
would rip the cover off to 180 no and I
would take a sixty seven sixty milligram
woman I need that one there's like two
in the air for them
do nothing to me I'll eat like a 60 and
I'd take the 180 and put in the 60
rapper Oh No and then I bring it to him
put it on the table
and in front of my go here and then open
it up from and he wouldn't see that it
was half open already uh I would give
him the 60 but it was in white last
night I gave him an expired one that had
a little bit of mold on it he he's gonna
be a good comic Oh bro he is gonna be a
good cop look at Eleanor I want to sat
there for 15 years shut her mouth and
watched there's a really special gift to
that yeah what do you think I almost
funny on that whether you agree with her
or not I give her the balls a lot of
people don't like just sitting there and
watching there's a lot of people that do
though you know there's a lot of people
that work in and around comedy clubs
that probably want to do it they just
don't know how to get started you know
they just don't have it in them to get
the ball rolling it's hard it's hard to
it's hard to try something new you keep
thinking about when's the right time to
do it is it now maybe shot wait a week
you know you know what I want to lose
ten pounds and then I'm gonna try and
you get all these things in your head